So leute da bin ich
auf klo
also war ich
Mir fällt gerade auf ich habe was wichtiges vergessen
und zwar mein vorschau rechner ist gar nicht an
ich sehe nichts
gescheit moment den muss ich mal kurz hochfahren
Säck so es dauert kurz also leute dankeschön für die subs
Und mich ein 50 billionen. Dankeschön
3 monats abo
Ich sehe nicht ich sehe nicht genau was du geschrieben hast weil der pepo davor ist und ich mein vorschau rechner nicht an habe und den
Jetzt nicht so eine ohne weiteres ausschalten kann
aber hauptsache
Der denzner pepo am start
So
Das sieht gut aus
So das sieht gut aus
Funktioniert
Genau das ist eigentlich für den sub
Der scam train ist am start
Name vom song das ist vvvv
Vvvvvvv
Bester name für den game
Okay das hört sich das hört sich auf englisch besser an die sagen ja wie
Dafür sagen sie zu weh aus irgendwelchen kunden w die sind
Jetzt wirklich nicht mehr ganz dicht ich brauche jetzt aber mal ein bisschen was anderes hier das war man hier heute zeigt mal ja
Ich brauche irgendwas
Entspannendes
Komm wir machen einfach ein bisschen
an und gut ist
Da kann nicht allzu viel schief gehen
Wupp wupp wupp wupp wupp wupp
Wupp wupp wupp du weintransfer gl hf
Ja heute richtig kerg java skript und zwar
Ich war meine vor allem an wenn es fangen wir heute mal an
Produktiver stream ja zumindest fangen wir heute mal an und zwar ich habe euch ja gesagt im letzten stream schon ich habe
Ich habe am wochenende mal ein bisschen geguckt
Damit ich meinen mein vorzeige open source projekt
bisschen groß vielleicht
mal ein bisschen über arbeit
Und das kriegt ein web interface spendiert zum besseren konfigurieren und dazu müssen wir ein bisschen keg java skript machen
dankeschön mülli
die kenne ich nicht
Also ich habe einige domains ich habe domains bei pork bun
nitrado habe ich tatsächlich noch modem und domains
name cheap
name silo
cloudflare
aber bei
Renom habe ich keine die kenne ich auch nicht
Wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich sind die billig wenn da sonst nichts funktioniert
Um so viele tabs offen der irgendwie muss ich ja rechtfertigen dass ich 64 gigabyte ramm habe oder nicht
Das schlimme ist mittlerweile sind browser relativ gut was das angeht
Die optimieren das in so weit dass ich kaum ramm brauche für die tabs
Du hast zu nehmen schiebt transfer das ist eine gute idee heute ist ja der erste
Deswegen fliegen hier die ganzen prime subs rein leute porc steinadler ja ich habe ganz vergessen erster
Prime subscriptions hier
So sieht es aus da habe ich ja gar nicht mehr dran gedacht sind da sinnvolle domains dabei
Ja aber ganz wenige also
Also mindestens eine sinnvolle domain ist dabei
Du musst nur gucken wenn du eine de domain hast eine netto wenn du die e domain hast dann kannst du nicht zu cloudflare
transferieren ich hätte ja persönlich
Eigentlich alles bei cloudflare wenn die de domains hätten
Heck wehpunkt service ja das ist das ist prinzipiell die beste domain wow was will er dann hier
Monkeys ruby standard live will be installed before is ruby dependency
oh nein
Monkeys
Schweizer ist heute schweizer nationaler schweizer feiertag
Was was feiern die schweizer denn heute die eidgenossen
Ist immer die geilste umschreibung was das sagen die den nachrichten und im fernsehprogramm immer so gern die eidgenossen
Ich weiß gar nicht was die da geeidet haben
Rebooten war schadet nix
Das wie gesagt beste beste
Dschiko was sie ist
Okay, tschiko ist an mir vorbei geflitzt
Und geht jetzt in die ecke neben am sofa
Was können die da nicht
Ach du meinst ip aktualisieren für deine fritzbox oder von deiner fritzbox oder sowas in der richtung
Wird mich jetzt echt wundern wenn cloudflare das nicht kann
so
Also ich zeige euch jetzt erkläre ich jetzt mal was wir machen also ich kann euch jetzt aber heute eins sagen also es ist
Jetzt 20 uhr 10 wir legen jetzt das projekt an wir basteln ein bisschen css bisschen zwölf bisschen javascript und sowas
Super krasse high-IQ
Funktionalität werden wir heute nicht bauen das kann ich euch gleich schon sagen
Das kriege ich in eineinhalb stunden nicht gescheit hin da muss ich muss ich bett gebett gehen
Außerdem war es auf der arbeit relativ anstrengend wir haben heute wieder
also den ganzen tag
Kubernetes allerdings
Wieder uns stundenlang mit einem kaputten in helmschaden vom hersteller rumgeschlagen ist wirklich was das angeht der schlechteste hersteller
Und die ekligste installation im koalitionsklasse die ich je gesehen habe hat das darf ich ja gar nicht sagen
Ist die ekligste ist die ekligste helm installation ich je gesehen habe
Und insofern ey leute ich sage euch was der hersteller sich da ausdenkt
Keine ahnung ipv6 keck w aber was hat was hatte wie lands mit die dynamik dns zu tun
Da pflege ich nicht mehr durch
Kennt jemand schon open wisp ist das als alternative zu den ubiquity
kenne ich nicht
sagt mir sagt mir gar nichts also ich kenne
Den folkmanagement system controller ich weiß gar nicht für was das überhaupt gedacht ist
Wer für welche für welche hardware ist das denn überhaupt gedacht ach open wrt okay
ne das kenne ich nicht
aber
Ich kenne vom vom sehen vom gucken diese tp link omada geschichte die fand ich auch nicht verkehrt
Gerade weil die auch features kann die ubiquity halt irgendwie einfach keinen bock hat zu unterstützen was auch der grund ist warum ich
nur mal neue exist points gekauft habe
So vor allem ist neu gestartet
haben was
auf geht's
Ja ja na ja nicht wirklich ganz komplett neu weil wir haben ja letztens schon mal so ein testprojekt angelegt aber das erste mal wirklich
was sinnvoll ist also
Ich versuche mal kurz zu erklären
also ich habe hier vor der ganzen weile mal ein
Home assistant add-on programmiert wie man hier sieht an den issues komplett fehlerfreies software hatte noch nie den einzigen bug
So wie ich das ja hier im stream auch euch immer versuch nahe zu bringen dass man komplett auf
Dokumentationen und tests und kommentare verzichten kann wenn einfach immer alles first try funktioniert
Natürlich alles hier user probleme kann ich ja nichts für wenn die nicht wissen wie man das richtig bedienen muss
Und es gibt zum ach jetzt kannst du jetzt willst du wieder raus okay?
Keine test keine fehler ja sehr alles alles selbst erklären first try funktioniert
so also
Und nachdem es vielleicht ein paar kleine unangenehmlichkeiten gibt ich würde natürlich nicht so weit gehen und sagen dass den fehler
Aber spaßbar es gibt ein paar sachen diese nicht so schön gelöst also ich habe dann ich habe
Den add-on programmiert für home assistant wo man sein fiat elektroauto wobei es ist nicht nur fiat es ist fiat jeep
Dodge trucks ram und alfa romeo die man die wie man die in seine heimautomatisierung reinbringen kann
Und da kann man sich dann im endeffekt so dashboards hier anlegen lassen wobei das ein home assistant dashboard ist mein add-on
Providet quasi nur die daten da drin so
Und das hat so ein paar kleinigkeiten die nicht so schön sind zum beispiel
Dass da multiple cars
Da wurde sogar schon gesamt abt also
Genau der hat mehrere jeeps mit unterschiedlichen accounts das funktioniert aktuell nicht du kannst aktuell genau ich kann solche sieht man das
man kann aktuell genau
Einen hersteller mit einem account konfigurieren in den optionen mehr geht nicht
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt als ich das entworfen habe nicht daran gedacht dass es leute gibt die
Schlicht und ergreifend mehrere accounts mit mehreren autos haben ja ich habe daran gedacht dass es vielleicht jemand gibt der einen fiat hat und
Auch einen zweiten fiat aber dass jemand quasi vom klein von dieser gleichen herstellergruppe
Zwei unterschiedliche autohersteller unter mehrere autos habe ich daran gedacht kommt aber vor ist so gar nicht möglich damit abzufackeln
Und das ist von home assistant das settingmenü das ist insgesamt ein bisschen
Ja bis ein bisschen eingeschränkt was man da alles machen kann
Deswegen werde ich ein paar sachen fixen
Da sind genug offene issues da ja multiple cars refreshintervall den man nicht richtig einstellen kann teilweise probleme bei neuen home assistant installationen
Irgendwelche units sind kaputt der alfa romeo support ist auch broken also manche manche sachen sind relativ kaputt
Und ich habe mir das überlegt wir werden das jetzt folgendermaßen machen also neben dem dass wir die ganzen bugs mal irgendwann fixen müssen
Ich sage ihr dürft übrigens mitmachen wenn ihr wollt ja so und
Ich habe mir überlegt wir können das so machen dass wir anstatt dieses home assistant config interface benutzt zu benutzen ein eigenes mini
integriertes web interface
Einbauen worüber man das ganze konfiguriert hat und dann die ganzen bugs fixen
Worüber man das ganze konfigurieren kann und da wollte ich heute mal ein projekt anlegen frontend projekt anlegen vielleicht auch ein bisschen schon
So grob das wird ja nicht super kompliziert da gibt es ein batten neues auto hinzufügen accounts daten eingeben und so was
Ja dürft ihr dürft ihr auch aber nur agile
Und diagonal vertikal horizontal
3d skaliert
Der fun fact hat vor allem ja ich weiß ich weiß
Wir haben einen hochverfügbaren kram master
Der entscheidet automatisch wer heute dailies kram master ist das ist
Wie wir außerdem machen wir keine scrums wir machen wir machen scrum mit micro sprints
Wir machen immer eine stunde programmieren eine stunde retro eine stunde planning
Eine stunde review und dann wieder machen wir wieder eine stunde was das heißt wir arbeiten nur zwei stunden am tag
Das ist das ist mein plan für das projekt dass es auch schön produktiv fertig und fertig wird was sind die nachteile von dem home assistant interface
Ja dass du manche sachen nicht darin abfackeln kannst zum beispiel du kannst nicht einstellen hier so ohne weiteres
mehrere accounts du kannst du könntest du könntest zwar das ding hier total auf blähen so nach dem motto
Login user 1 login user 2 aber du weißt ja nicht vielleicht hat einer zwei fiat
Accounts und ein jeep account ist das das funktioniert nicht so richtig
Du brauchst du brauchst mehrere logins
Man braucht irgendwie mal auch eine ordentliche anzeige wenn was nicht funktioniert was es hier auch nicht gibt kannst höchstens ins lock gucken
also insofern
Wir werden sowas hier ähnliches machen aber halt ein bisschen ein bisschen schöner und es ist dann übrigens auch in home assistant integriert
Nein kann man nicht weil das keine home assistant integration ist sondern eine home assistant add-on
Und add-ons sind docker container die einzeln laufen das kannst du nur einmal adden wenn das geht wäre das wahrscheinlich halb so wild wenn man
Das add-on mehrfach hinzufügen könnte und der nächste punkt warum ich mir gedacht habe ein eigenes web interface ist nicht verkehrt
weil mich schon einige leute
Ein ist es nicht das ist das ist ein add-on guck das kannst du hier über das add-on repo hinzufügen
nicht über hacks sondern über add-ons in der oberfläche
Und mich haben hier schon ein paar leute gefragt wie es mit stand-alone betrieb und sowas aussieht
Das ist auch nicht schön zu konfigurieren
denke unterm strich sind wir besser wenn das ein integriertes web interface hat
und
Der macht mqtt richtig und man kann das ganze ja trotzdem im home assistant
Integrieren weil wenn du auf das add-on gehst dann machst du einfach den ingress modus an und dann ist das in der home assistant oberfläche
Embedded aber du hast dein eigenes web interface wurde das add-on besser konfigurieren kannst so
Also es gibt ein paar sachen die gemacht werden müssen das machen aber heute bei weitem nicht alles heute das werden wir irgendwie nur
So verteilt wenn es mir danach ist über ein paar streams verteilt machen also wir müssen web interface bauen dafür dass es halbwegs halbwegs
funktioniert
und
Dann müssen wir mal die ganzen bugs die natürlich keine bugs sondern ihr wisst schon user fehler sind müssen wir auch mal irgendwann fixen
und einbauen dass mehrere mehrere
Hersteller unterstützt sind dass das hier dort schon alpha romeo funktioniert haben sich ja schon leute gemeldet
Das ist ja auch nicht den browser den ich normalerweise verwende ich verwende ja normalerweise den da
schon besser aus oder
nutzt du eigentlich happyfire
Ich weiß nicht mal was happyfire ist
ist das
bist du der bist du der autor von happyfire und willst werbung machen
kommt wir sind wir sind mal nicht so
Happyfire 24 sterne das gibt zu
Coldclown das doch von dir oder
Exposed und heute werden wir einfach mal das projekt anlegen
Das backen projekt das frontend projekt also ich werde ich werde dass das allermeiste wahrscheinlich hier raus
Copypasten wenn es an die backen logik geht aber ich habe ein paar ich habe aus ein paar fehlern gelernt ja zum beispiel
Ja macht jetzt eigentlich keinen sinn das zu zeigen
Aber nur zum beispiel das handling von den commands ist übelst bescheuert gemacht
Wo man an sein auto schicken kann was es machen soll ja
Das sieht jetzt vielleicht nicht so eklig aus aber ist ziemlich eklig
Da muss ich da muss ich noch ein bisschen was bisschen was verbessern das heißt wir legen jetzt mal ein neues projekt an das nennen wir
auch mal ganz
hier 4
weil letzte release version ist
3.08
Also gibt es vier 4 das wird dann aber im endeffekt in das gleiche repo reinkommen nein ich mache keinen kompletten rewrite
Ich werde also naja zumindest schon mal nicht in rust
Ihr müsst gar nicht wieder anfangen heute ups den wollte ich gar nicht und auch nicht den c++
Ich werde ich werde das meiste backend mäßig hier mehr mehr raus copypasten was ich hier schon habe
Runden schon rust und webassembly klar das ist natürlich das
Die einzig wahre technologie dafür wenn man eine publische webseite braucht rust webassembly frontend
Es gibt nichts anderes was man machen kann
Aber wir machen zwölf und zwölf kit das ist auch most loved technologie laut stackoverflow
Und zwölf ist auch glaube ich was frontend angeht blazingly fast
Aber aber natürlich nix ist so blazingly fast wie rust logischerweise
Weil das sagen die leute immer für rust also muss das muss das so sein
Wir machen mal kurz in eine neue .net version installieren ich glaube da gab es letztens wieder was
Ne wir machen auch nicht htmx wir machen ein zwölf kit also wir machen ganz normales .net backend projekt
logischerweise weil
Das ist eine .net anwendung
Bisher noch ohne webserver und alles aber das meiste hiervon werde ich wahrscheinlich kopieren ich meine es macht ja keinen sinn
Die ganzen response klassen für das jason zeug von fiat
Irgendwie nicht zu kopieren warum soll ich die warum soll ich die warum soll ich die neu bauen ist ja komplett sinnlos meine ich
Komplett sinnlos meine die die sehen halt so aus wie sie aussehen da kann ich jetzt nicht so viel
Und so ein paar sachen also das meiste das meiste wenn wir davon übernehmen
Höchstwahrscheinlich auch die interaktion mit dem home assistant mqtt und so was da will man wenn man es nicht so viel
Nicht so viel dran ändern aber es kommt webserver dazu und es kommt ein webfrontend dazu das heißt wir legen jetzt mal das projekt an
Backend und frontend und basteln schon ein bisschen css und sowas
Mir ist heute auch tatsächlich ein bisschen der frontend stells aber ihr wisst ich hoffe sind css kenner da das wird das wird wieder was
Das machen wir heute dann gibt es ein schönes webinterface
Um das zu konfigurieren vor allem wenn man das ganze stand alone betreiben will ist das sehr nice
Er den auskennt fuchs brauchen wir dann so fiat champ 4
alles klar
Helmet daisy ui 9 skeleton ui
das da weil ich mir das das letzte mal geguckt habe und eigentlich
Ganz nice fand ich meine es hat ein blazingly fast rocket theme das
Kann nicht schlecht sein
Und es hat pop ups mit komischen skeletten
Und und ganz wichtig den dark und light theme switch
Was ist hier los ich habe da ein problem ich möchte gern auf mein arbeitsnotebook linux haben das ist eine gute idee
Habe aber zum beispiel fusion fusion trend das ist was um 3d druckzeug zu bauen oder so
Ja, sowas in der richtung
Über wine soll das wohl auch nicht so gut sein kann mir eine lösung sagen wie ich das am besten mache
Also ehrlich wenn das eines also ich weiß ja nicht wie es ist also wenn das eines deiner hauptanwendungszwecke ist was du auf
Notebook machst dann ist linux keine gute idee
Wenn du das nur ab und an wusste mal sagen wie oft du das benutzt wenn du das nur mal
Einmal im monat nimmst oder so
Dann wäre es vielleicht gut du guckst dich nach alternativen um was es unter linux gibt
Alternativ
Kannst du gut machen dual boot sagt aber
Kann es auch gucken ob es ordentlich in der vm läuft aber wahrscheinlich eher
nicht so gut
Du kannst aber auch so machen wie ich
Du kannst windows auf dem notebook behalten und linux in der vm installieren
Gibt mehr gibt viele möglichkeiten also ich persönlich finde das ist das beste setup
Wenn man windows und linux parallel benutzen will aber das willst du ja gar nicht also ich will das weil ich für
Videos schneiden samt eine bearbeitung streaming und spielen will ich windows haben für alles andere will ich linux haben deswegen ist für mich
Ein windows mit linux in der vm eigentlich das beste was es gibt
Für dich wahrscheinlich eher nicht bei dir sieht es ja so aus als willst du wirklich 99 prozent linux benutzen
Ja also ganz ehrlich die beste alternative wäre ich weiß jetzt nicht was fusion 360
So alles macht ob es da alternativen gibt unter linux
gibt ja mittlerweile für 3d drucker auch
Man kann auch bestimmt auch in blender 3d drucker machen oder
Geht ja mittlerweile bestimmt also wenn du web anwendungen hast web anwendungen sind prinzipiell immer das beste die laufen überall
Das ist das einfachste für dich wäre du suchst dir irgendeine alternative
Linux als vm geht auch ich habe vor allem bei workstation
Du kannst damit alles wunderbar machen es gibt ein paar kleine einschränkungen
Also wenn du jetzt 3d heavy sachen machen willst also ich würde jetzt also blender blender kann man machen
Auch in der vm das funktioniert aber naja
Also vielleicht nicht vielleicht nicht unbedingt das beste wenn du wenn du videos schauen willst in der vm zum beispiel mit
Also youtube videos die kannst du zwar in der vm gucken die versuchungssachen aber enorm viel cpu last weil die
Grafikkarte nicht zum decoden benutzt werden kann von videos
Da muss man sich überlegen was einmal wichtiger ist ich würde sagen das einfachste dürfte sein
Du guckst dir mal an ob es irgendwelche sinnvollen alternativen dafür gibt was unter linux läuft
Und wenn du da was findest kannst du ausprobieren
Ansonsten wenn du eh noch nicht so viel ahnung von linux hast dann würde ich dir tatsächlich die kombination empfehlen
Windows weiter als hostbetriebssystem und linux in der vm da kannst du es auch so machen wie ich auf dem ersten desktop windows auf dem zweiten desktop einfach
Linux
Ja so sieht es aus so also wir erstellen mal unser projekt
Und zwar mal gucken ob ich es auf die reihe kriege jetzt wie das mit mit zwölf und zwölf kit noch mal funktioniert hat wir
Haben das ja erst vor einem monat oder so gemacht also wir brauchen erst mal ein back-end projekt
Also ich schluckt ich strukturiert das meistens ganz gerne so ich mache hier in den github
an der stelle so
Dann lege ich ein ordner an für back-end ein ordner für sagen wir sowas wie web oder sowas
und hier drinne
mache ich dann mein .NET new
Ich glaube web entweder web oder web api ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
Ich glaube web ist das richtige
Dann hier lege ich hier mein .NET projekt drinnen an
Das öffnen wir gleich schon mal in rider
Guten abend ich bin auch relativ neu welche distribution nutzt du denn aktuell arch linux by the way beste hier
neo fetch
einzig wahre
arch by the way use ich
Und und das solltest du auch unbedingt usen und wenn du dann anfängst arch zu usen
Dann musst du selbstverständlich allen täglich mehrfach sagen
Dass du arch benutzt das ist das ist da way nur so geht das
Ich hätte rider nicht hier drüber öffnen sollen
sondern lieber so
Wie warum hat sich das rider nicht gemerkt in der historie was ist was ist da los
repos 4 champ 4
Backend
Backend open zack trust
gachi buss ja ja er hat eros er hat eros im projekt weil rider immer zu blöd ist
zu checken bei neuen projekten
Dass er die mit dem lokal installierten .NET aufmachen soll und nicht mit dem global installierten .NET
Pass auf einmal umstellen und schon funktioniert es wieder ich weiß nicht warum rider da so rum backt
zack aber das hier jetzt brauchen wir ein frontend projekt
Da gehen wir eins hoch legen hier in den ordner die ordner haben wir schon für web und jetzt stehe ich auf dem schlauch
du benutzt bsd
Ja kann man auch machen
Aber das ist nicht arch und dementsprechend ist es inferior weil arch ist das einzig wahre
Ich lasse ich lasse mir vielleicht noch gentoo jeden tag selbst kompilieren gefallen aber alles andere wird es eng
ungefragt korrekt du musst du musst den leuten immer wenn es ums thema linux erzählen dass du selbstverständlich auch arch benutzt
Ja achso und um auf deine frage zurückzukommen das ist arch linux mit i3 ich glaube das steht doch hier auch irgendwo
i3 als window manager wobei window gut ist aber gut der kann auch sowas wie windows managen hier window window manager geht auch
übrigens die hintergründe sind auch absolut
so da hast du i3 als window manager beziehungsweise eigentlich eher als
Tiling window manager da hast du standardmäßig alles im fullscreen oder halt gesplittert oder so oder je nachdem wie du den klampel verteilst
und als terminal western
Falls du dich interessiert wie ich das konfiguriert habe wenn du dich dafür interessiert dann kannst du hier gucken
habt den ganzen mist
eigentlich dort
nicht eingegeben
Hier hast du meine ganze konfig für den prompt fürs terminal
Für i3 für icons für
Zeug was sind denn private default index was habe ich da committed
Nix nix nix private nix geheimes
bsd für den server
Kann man machen ich persönlich bin mittlerweile wieder auf dem jahren gelandet was server angeht außer auf der arbeit
da muss ich leider mein geld mit red hat verdienen aber
Ansonsten bin ich auch wieder weg von ubuntu ubuntu ist ja gerade im cloud umfeld sehr beliebt aber ich muss ehrlich sagen
debian
So sei seit einem jahr ungefähr oder seit eineinhalb jahren wieder hauptsächlich debian
Kannst du auch mal so eine zeile anzeigen welche tasten kombination gedrückt wurde du wirst
bis lang genau das habe ich mir vor ein zwei tagen überlegt ob das nicht so gute idee wäre ein overlay von der tastatur aber
auf der anderen seite
Erstens passiert nicht so viel kompliziertes und zweitens gehe ich auch gerne auf den zweiten monitor und tippt da irgendwas was ich nicht will dass
Ihr seht dass ihr das seht ihr seht dann zwar nicht was ich tippe aber ihr seht meine tasten könnte das theoretisch wenn ich passwörter tippe
so rekonstruieren
Das funktioniert nicht da ist mir das risiko auch zu hoch irgendwelche passwörter oder andere sachen zu liegen die ich auf dem zweiten monitor schreibe
Ansonsten
Ist benutze ich nicht sonderlich viele komplexen
Shortcuts ich benutze windows taste 1 2 3 zum umschalten zwischen meinen desktops ich benutze shift windows taste zum desktop
Umschalten zwischen hier windows und linux
Das war es eigentlich
Du hast eh schon keylogger installiert fuck
Jetzt bin ich gelieferter
So also skeleton ui wie hat das jetzt noch mal funktioniert
docs getting started
Npm create skeleton app latest
Chat g wer von euch ist five head frontend guru und kann mir erklären warum das hier funktioniert
Ohne dass ich skeletons vorher installiert habe geht geht npm create
irgendwie auf
Auf github und guckt nach oder woher weiß es das oder die npm
Guckt auf npm ob es dort ein paket gibt was so heißt und führt dann dort was aus oder wie funktioniert das
Weil ich habe ich muss skeleton nicht in skeleton app nicht dafür installieren vorher mit npm also wie funktioniert das überhaupt
Npm schaut immer online nach ja wahrscheinlich
Das ist high IQ
Ich meine ist eigentlich auch ganz gut
Npm müllt uns jetzt gleich mit dem halben internet die platte voll passt mal auf so
Npm create latest ich würde übrigens gerne im gleichen verzeichnis generaten falls das geht und das funktioniert
Da guckt mal an ich hoffe das funktioniert im gleichen verzeichnis weil es kann sein dass er den app namen für irgendwas benutzt
Ich glaube wir brechen noch mal kurz ab ich mache hier trotzdem noch web bester name für eine für eine anwendung
So do you want to use typescript js nein wollen wir nicht
wollen wir
es lind
Da wäre das ja irgendwie fast lesbar ja max das muss ich unbedingt gleich
Da wäre das fast lesbar unitess brauchen wir eh nicht tailwind forms brauchen wir tailwind typography
codeblocks popups alles rein
select a theme ja die fall theme skeleton welcome page install
Was hältst du dankeschön übrigens für den sub was hältst du von black mirror?
Denkst du das wird die zukunft ich das sagt mir gar nix
Ist das ist das javascript frontend zeug oder was soll das sein?
serie
Aber warum soll ich denken das wird die zukunft
Ach du meinst ob die zu 8 das ist eine serie über die zukunft ob ich mein ob die zukunft so wird wie doch
Keine ahnung kenne ich nicht ach jetzt habe ich es gecheckt ich habe ganz wenig neues javascript framework ich mein
Wäre das so unwahrscheinlich dass es black mirror punkt js gebe
So wie viel note modules hatten der gute eigentlich jetzt installiert so web run def ja geht nicht
Wir rannen das mal das auch alles installiert wird so ist okay oder war vorher schon
Wie gut so chat schätzt mal wie groß ist meine demo anwendung
Also mit note modules und allem dabei aber aber hauptsache ein weekly download ja
420 hier gucken wir mal ein
Warum ist das nur so wenig
Warum sind das nur 91 da kommt ja gleich noch ein bisschen was dabei da kommen ja noch icons und alles mögliche zeug
91 das erscheint mir aber sehr wenig das muss man gleich mal tape tabler icons installieren das ganze mal ein bisschen
bisschen fetter zu machen
Okay, ja schon besser schon besser
Jetzt jetzt gehen wir so langsam in richtung ordentliches frontend projekt jetzt sind wir schon mal 330 mb
Schon schon gleich viel viel leiser
So ein ein problem gibt es jetzt allerdings nur
Dass ich jetzt ein ordner habe web in dem noch ein ordner web ist das ist ziemlich doof
Deswegen benenne ich den ordner web in keckel um das dürfte viel viel besser sein
dann move ich den ordner keckel 1 hoch und
Rename keckel zu web aber jetzt habe ich wieder da drin ich kann nur und dann er ähme ich wer
und move
Keckel zu web so
Und jetzt haben wir den ganzen krempel hier drinnen jawohl unser frontend projekt ist am start
Dann können wir mich als studio code aufmachen rider machen wir auf dem vierten bildschirm
wischtel studio code machen wir auf den dritten desktop
so
Ich traste den autoren aber sowas von können wir uns vorstellen
So da haben wir hier den kram
Roots default pages
Bisschen groß oder
Ach komm wir haben ja viel platz im also was habe ich denn hier für eine size für die schriftart ist ja massiv
Das ist sogar mir ein bisschen zu fett
Chasen settings oder config oder
Einfach settings
User settings da machen wir hier font size jetzt 20 okay das ist ein bisschen zu krass
Das vielleicht ein bisschen zu klein um 18
Ja 18 ist gut
Aber das andere war ein bisschen zu fett und wir wollen natürlich zwei taps oder zwei leerzeichen
warum wischtel studio code
Ich habe eine andere frage an dich
warum nicht
Was denn sonst?
Okay, webstorm vielleicht oder
notepad plus plus
Das ist nicht ganz richtig für heute
JetBrains zeug ja verwenden wir fürs back-end front-end ist wischtel studio code beste
kein Wim
Wim werden wir bestimmt drehen beste drehen wie vor mx leute
Erst mal installieren hier drehen wie vor mx 2004
jawohl
Damit sollten wir jetzt die webanwendung entwickeln das ist gut
Oder
Frontpage
atom ist
Microsoft eingestampft
So dann
Brauchen wir mal hier ein
npm run def
Und dann sehen wir das hierauf
Was läuft war mal chrome auf im richtigen fenster
chrome
zack localhost
Easy da sind wir nice
Session
Da sind wir am start
Demo anwendung läuft
Backend macht absolut gar nichts zurzeit
Außer hello world auszugeben
Das heißt das müssen wir noch mal schnell ändern
Repos fiat champ 4
back-end dotnet run
Okay funktioniert prinzipiell jetzt müssen wir noch folgendes einstellen also wir werden wir werden ganz klein anfangen
Erst mal gucken dass das ordentlich kompiliert alles und dass es den richtigen ordner bildet
Das meine dass man back-end auch die frontend applikationen ausliefert und sowas wird heute der fiat champ im prüft ja
Hat er jetzt eigentlich ans welt und das welt kit das welt kit projekt erstellt
Heute fangen wir an mit dem webinterface für den fiat champ
Wir machen eine ganz ganz mini back-end anwendung erst mal also sagen hier map get api
api slash
immer
Id
Id und die int id muss man glaube ich dann hier auch schreiben int id
Cw id ich will einfach nur gucken ob es funktioniert return results
Okay und ja keine ahnung
Cw so beste bestart tp response überhaupt
Verwendest du i3 mit mehreren monitoren wie ist das so
Ich verwende i3 nicht mit mehreren monitoren nee ich habe aber früher auf der arbeit i3 mit mehreren monitoren verwendet
mit
einem notebook monitor und einem großen curved frag mich nicht
30 32 zoll monitor oder sowas das ging relativ gut die haben das geändert
Das kommt darauf an was du verwendest wenn du die minimal api verwendest dann war das schon immer so
in
Im controller war es glaube ich
Da war es da glaube ich sowas wie okay
result genau
Ja
Das ist neu also was was du kennst ist wahrscheinlich noch das mit controllern
Ich meine das hier ist die gesamte web anwendung das ist das minimal api was ich was nicht verkehrt ist für unseren fall
Wir brauchen ja im endeffekt gar nicht so viel so also wir haben eine back-end anwendung
Anwendung ist gut ja eine back-end anwendung
Die aktuell genau achso moment wir müssen ja noch den port umstellen wo das ganze lauschen soll
Erstmal das ist das ist auch so ein ding wo ich mir denke meine güte wer zum teufel lässt denn wirklich seine sachen mit
Iis laufen gibt es auf dieser welt echt noch jemand der neue anwendung entwickelt explizit für iis
Ich habe ich habe keine ahnung was mit microsoft los ist was sie sich damit diesen default settings denken
Schätzchen wie sieht es bei euch aus
Iis habt ihr noch is anwendung also neue
So
Ein bestimmter ein oder andere aber dass das das default mäßig drinnen steht ist halt echt hardcore
bbga
So https brauchen wir auch overrated outdated
Http ist gut hier iis settings braucht auch keiner
sagt profiles http
Command name ich weiß nicht was der will von mir.net run messages launch browser
Ja application url ist gut application mal keine ahnung port 50 50 oder sowas
So ran du benutzt iis auch für neues zeug
So curl localhost port 50 50 jawohl geht nicht
Slash geht nicht 1 kek b sehr schön razor pages
Dann ist das dann ist das eine sehr windows heavy sache
vermutlich
Weil ich kenne auch wenige sachen die noch mit razor pages arbeiten außer blazer blazer verwendet ja auch diese die razor page syntax
Aber reines razor pages server side komplett gerendert
sieht man wenig
Ist aber nicht so als wäre ich hauptberuflicher.net entwickler also weiß nicht wie es wirklich im enterprise business aussieht aber
Mir kommt so vor als sehe ich kaum razor anwendung
Okay, die anwendung funktioniert
Exzellent da können wir jetzt mal gleich gucken ob unser frontend drauf zugreifen kann
Das werden wir erst mal alles löschen das braucht ja keiner das kommt weg
Und es kommt auch hier alles weg
Kecke
optimal
Glaube das ist das ist die geilste seite überhaupt so layout kommt auch erst mal das ganze zeug weg
da kommt
Im endeffekt schreiben wir hier nur rein
hier
Der schöne überschrift nice kommen lassen wir das so drinnen
Das braucht eigentlich keiner sieht man doch anhand den dinger so umstellen auf zwei spaces gut
So jetzt können wir mal gucken ob wir da auf unser backend projekt zugreifen können die lead everything ja haben wir ja schon
Schauen wir mal script ups wo tippe ich denn
Script an fetch request blenden wir mal browser
Konsole ein fetch also hier result gleich
Await
Fetch
Ache breit geht da nicht
Kann
Ganz welt nicht top level await
oder so was
wait
Ich meine ich kann eine funktion machen
was im laut modul
Okay, die sind hier ganz schön am diskutieren
Die man muss es doch gar nicht so kompliziert machen ich meine ich kann auch einfach so was hier machen
Main
das funktioniert auch aber schon ein bisschen
Gepega wo was ist jetzt warum ist es jetzt
Crash das
Http doppelpunkt doppel slash keckel.de
besser
Ach weil das serverzeit versucht dass du aber das sollte doch nicht der ganze def server crashen ich übrigens ich würde gerne
Ich würde gerne komplette serverzeit rendering ausschalten brauche ich nicht ich werde es eh statisch statisch
Rändern und in www root ordner legen
Wart mal hier zwölf kit
disable ssr
you you now do
Export konst ssr gleich falls
in einer datei roots layout
Moment layout punkt gs aber
Out plus layout punkt gs
also so im endeffekt
Okay, so hier können wir eintragen http
localhost port 50 50 a p slash 1
Und ich kriege als antwort ich habe kurs nicht konfiguriert in asp.net
Ich darf ja okay das ist ja relativ logisch dass es nicht funktioniert weil
Guckt mal das hier ist der host von dem die seite ausgeliefert wurde wurde und hier auf port
5050 das ist eine ganz andere seite und
die seite sagt
also
Ich will nicht dass seiten die nicht die die ich nicht ausgeliefert habe irgendwie auf meinen kontent zugreifen
Ja, das muss man das muss man explizit setzen muss ich überlegen wie das jetzt funktioniert hat ich glaube
Ich glaube man konnte irgendwie sagen kurs oder sowas just kurs genau
Aber musste den kram noch konfigurieren
kurs policy bilder er hier
Konfig
Ja, so ging das
ab
Den ich ab konfig. Oh leute ich muss mal kacken gleich
Pipo pipo feuer toilet fire zoom muss ich gleich machen
allow any header genau
allow any header allow any
method allow any
Any
origin das braucht man
Ich glaube das hot reload hat nicht funktioniert
Schauen wir mal ob das. Oh was jetzt was was was was was was hier warum ist es jetzt kaputt
Worte was will der von mir
Nur los pancakes danke für den sub
Was hat jetzt ach ich weiß woran es liegt man muss glaube ich noch ins services
bilder services
kurs ja
Okay schon besser schon besser
Ja jetzt funktioniert auch der zugriff da drauf weil ich mir nicht ganz sicher bin
Ob ich das richtig richtig konfiguriert habe so an der stelle
Weil es gibt ja auch noch die möglichkeit ist hier zu konfigurieren was ist denn da jetzt der unterschied
Options
Default policy ach jetzt könnte ich das hier quasi
Hinzufügen oder wie aber wo ist da der sinn von kann ich das jetzt einfach so machen
Ja keine ahnung was da besser ist das dann lassen wir das so so und
Was wir noch machen müssen ist
if
app environment
ist
Ist development wir wollen das nur machen
Wenn wir im entwicklungsmodus sind
Entwicklungsmodus sind
Für wie weit in rast ich muss mal ganz kurz eine runde pepo pepo pupu machen ich bin gleich wieder am start
so
Da bin ich wieder
Erledigt alles
Gut wo sind wir stehen geblieben hier champ keckel sind wir stehen geblieben
Genau ich wollte gucken ob ich zugreifen kann von meinem front end auf meinen back end
Technisch ob das soweit alles in der in der entwicklung funktioniert
Weil also wir wollen das ja nur wenn environment development ist
Also gucken wir mal
Lock
Text
Ob das muss man auch erwarten
Ja okay funktioniert keck weh gibt es von der api zurück
Alles gut nice ich denke wir später noch noch den einen noch einen bootloader neu schreiben good luck have fun
assembler time
Ich weiß dass das debate ist
Niemand schreibt ein bootloader aber einfach so
Magst ans trinken erinnern sehr gute usage von deinen channel points
Okay, also das funktioniert schon mal
Nächstes ding ist
Wie baut man so eins welt kit projekt ich habe das schon eine ganze weile nicht mehr gemacht
bild welt kit bild
Wie funktioniert das okay npm run bild ja da auf die idee wäre ich wäre ich auch noch gekommen
lara will
Also das was ich von php und lara wenn du letztens
Letztens gesehen habe hat mich jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig überzeugt wenn ich mir das doch mal ab und bilden die anwendung
und dann
Moment
Was konnten not detect supported production environment
Was will er von mir ich würde das gerne öffnen
Da will ich das öffnen was will er bevor ihr kennt die pläne aus welt kit app you need to
Adapte es ach nee ich will static ich will adapter static haben
Ja genau
Npm i minus d adapter static
Also ich will ich will das so
Rendern dass ich das ganz normal in webserver das ausliefern kann und dann ist gut
Denn er hat die adapter to your swell konfig
Er ist welt konfig adapter nicht adapter auto sondern adapter
Nicht adapter auto sondern adapter static
Das müsste soweit es eigentlich funktioniert haben und
Dann die fall options are shown below pre-render option to your route layout
This can be false if you're using a fallback
spa mode
Ja, das klingt aber nach was was ich haben will
Was ich spa mode ich will spa mode haben
Ja, das habe ich das habe ich doch schon gemacht
Fallback, okay, das ist sinnvoll
Das sollten wir tatsächlich machen ein fallback
Dass wenn ich irgendeinen fad eingebe
Den es nicht gibt dass der mich redirected
Auf meine single page application
Ja, das wäre wahrscheinlich ganz sinnvoll
Machen wir mal ein fallback was index html heißt
fallback
index html
Ganze stelle wiederum auf zwei tabs
So und jetzt gucken wir mal ob wir es bilden können
Das sieht doch deutlich besser aus so wo kommt das bild jetzt raus
Punkt bild gibt es ein ordner bild
Fafikon und index html das sieht gut aus wie sieht so die index html aus
Bild index html
Bis sie abgedrehte einrückung aber okay soll mir recht sein
Promise all was auch immer da macht so und das muss jetzt von meiner backend anwendung ausgeliefert werden
So das heißt wir brauchen schon mal noch einen weiteren punkt wir brauchen hier drin einen ordner
für meine webseite
Veroth
Und wir müssen das konfigurieren dass der statische seiten surft aus diesem ordner
Veroth ich bilde mir ein das ist ziemlich easy gewesen
Jus static files genau just file server ist das richtige
Wenn ich das richtige erinnerung habe
Checken wir das doch gerade mal
Einfach eine index html lieber dann gleich wieder löschen gucken ob das ob das funktioniert
das heißt wenn ich jetzt hier auf
local host port 50 50 gehen dann
Okay, gibt es meine index html gut heißt das funktioniert
gut das heißt meine
Frontend anwendung muss jetzt nach dem bilden in diesen www root ordner
also bild
Run bild wenn das bild fertig ist dann
Moven wir den bild ordner
Wobei eigentlich nur den inhalt vom bild ordner nach einem ordner nach oben
backend www root
Feuer informiert du hast bereits prettier als formatieren in deinem projekt dort kannst du auch deine einrückung einstellung mit temp wird
ja
Wäre eigentlich sinnig also ich habe das ich habe das nicht im projekt ich habe das glaube ich im
Mein virtual studio code hat glaube ich default mäßig sowas eingestellt
prettier konfiguriert doch habe ich hier auch tatsächlich
Aha
So chrome
local host port 50 50 dann schauen wir doch mal sagt funktioniert nice
Also nachdem die app gebaut wird wird die hier statisch ausgeliefert sehr schön das gefällt mir
Websocket was will was willst du websocket
asp.net core browser refresh
ich weiß nicht genau was er will aber
Ich will mich nicht per websocket verbinden ach das ist wahrscheinlich weil ich das hier per watch gestartet habe
Ja, ich will die seite gar nicht refreshen dass da kommt mein statisches bild raus das auto auto reload habe ich hier
Das liegt wahrscheinlich daran ja guckt das lag daran dass ich mit.net watch run gestartet habe
Okay, also das funktioniert da bin ich bin ich happy nice
Gut
run def
Dann können wir jetzt ja loslegen das ganze ein bisschen zu stylen
Wie könnte man so einen webinterface ich glaube ich habe jetzt alles so weit so weit eingebaut wie es sein muss
Wie könnte man so einen webinterface bauen für die für die konfig dafür
Also ich würde sagen wir brauchen
hier eine anzeige mit bereits
Angelegten accounts also für fiat für
Ram oder sonst was und da drunter wird dann aufgelistet ob es gerade
Refreshed ob es aktiv ist beziehungsweise ob es fehler hat wie viele autos drinnen sind
Und ja last refresh time und refresh intervall und irgendwie sowas in der richtung
würde ich würde ich sagen
Macht doch sowas wie der ja ja ja sowas schwebt mir vor aber ihr wisst es ich bin nicht da in der krasseste webdesigner hacker man
was das angeht
So also dann dann machen wir doch mal hier eine karte def
class
hart
Und dann waren wir hier ich glaube p4 haben die inner
nice exzellent perfekt seit ist fertig
Left side navigation
Ich glaube ich glaube dass gar keine navigation nötig ist
weil
Mehr als eine seite weiß ich gar nicht ob ich mehr als eine seite überbrauch
Doch doch doch doch
Das home assistant add-on kriegt nur den webinterface dass man es besser konfigurieren kann
Und damit kannst du es auch ordentlich stand alone benutzen viele leute haben nämlich geschrieben sie wünschen dass ich auch stand alone benutzen zu können
Für beispielsweise io broker oder sowas irgendwo kannst du sie mit irgendeinem x beliebigen mqtt server verbinden sind die css klassen
Mit ins welt drehen oder macht das tailwind das macht tailwind allerdings nicht nur tailwind sondern auch
Skeleton ui also diese karte klasse die ist in skeleton ui drin
so
Pass mal auf frontend frontend skills am start hier jetzt also wir brauchen eine karte so in die karte
sondern nein
in die karte
Kommt das muss ich mir angucken bei denen hier karte die haben noch bestimmt ein exempel für
Das ist das ist das ist alles das was skeleton ui mitbringt
Als ob so die scheiße auswendig von dem weiß ich nicht ach das hier meinst du
Nee das war im demo projekt drinne das wusste ich nicht auswendig das einzige was ich wusste ist karte und p4
Hier ist doch ein beispiel kommt mal hier header content footer perfekt
Das wird jetzt copy pasted
Exzellent so wollen wir das haben
So ist das doch was
Gut vielleicht p2 reicht wahrscheinlich kommt man mal p4
So da können wir jetzt was reinschreiben also ich würde sagen in den titel
Schreiben wir sowas wie den account und dann sowas wie irgendwie keine keckel at kappa 0.com
Je nachdem was es für eine e-mail adresse für den account hat also wir schreiben den hersteller
Und wir schreiben den die account e-mail adresse rein in den in den in den titel
Ich meine das sieht so noch ziemlich beschissen aus aber mal gucken was uns noch so einfällt
Dann
Brauchen wir
ein
Icon würde ich sagen so ein auto eiken oder sowas in der richtung dafür haben wir tabler
Ja, ebler tabler. Ah nice ich habe das sogar noch in der historie drin
Tabler eikens
Eiken trash feld
Okay, wenn ich das jetzt irgendwie da einfüge was passiert dann
Eine cpu geht auf 100 prozent auslastung, okay
Musst du jetzt erst noch irgendwie alle alle eikens kompilieren oder was?
Alter meine komplette
Ja, okay, da musst du erst irgendwie noch die sv sv gs erzeugen oder sowas zwar kann einfach mal kompletter rechner ausgelastet vom
refreshen der webseite
Only only in javascript
Gut, aber ich will kein eiken trash ich will den eiken gibt es sowas wie eiken
ach guck mal da
das kauf
Da müssen wir tabler eikens da müssen wir uns mal angucken was es da alles für eikens gibt mit einem auto drinne
ka
ka ka
Caravan ein moment es ist nicht kauf es ist carrot gewesen nicht kauf ka
Doch kauf das gibt ach das ist ausgeschaltetes auto
Okay, das ist nice dass die zwei verschiedene eikens dafür haben da können wir das sogar so disabled anzeigen um das hier weg
Okay, also dann würde ich sagen wir machen hier oben mal also
Ihr wisst ich bin kein krasser frontend hacker man das kann das sein dass das mega mega beschissen aussieht klein
So wir machen hier einmal eiken karen
Dann machen wir hier eine schrift rein ich glaube das müssen wir das müssen wir in extra diff packen
was gibt es das auch das
gibt es nicht
Ich als crash oder
Ach tatsächlich
Carcrash gibt es auch und guck mal es gibt sogar den abschlepp abschlepp auto gibt es auch komax dankeschön für den zapp
Gibt es sogar ein abschlepp auto ja das ist nice dass die dafür alle eikens haben aber die brauchen wir nicht
Brand mercedes
Moment moment
Haben die brand fiat
Nee ach schade
Haben die ram oder so oder
Haben die nicht
Aber guck mal mercedes ist einfach mal am start oder bmw
Nee auch nicht
wusste keine werbung schon danke für den zapp
Ach nee alter ich habe gerade gedacht es hat jemand 115
Du hast insgesamt 115 zapps also du hast mich gerade mega geschockt ich habe gerade nur gelesen hat 115 zapps gegiftet
Ich habe schon gedacht was zum teufel ist jetzt kaputt
danke für den gifte zapp hier klang
Kann die werbung jetzt dort schon relativ viele eikens drin
So das sieht jetzt das sieht ziemlich kacke aus oder was ich hier gebaut habe
Also machen wir mal was hier noch was anderes rein header flex dann sieht das schon mal alles auf einer ebene aus
Gap sieht schon mal ein bisschen ein bisschen gespaceter aus
so und dann
Leute ich habe
Flex vielleicht sollten wir noch item center machen wir machen die schrift hier ein bisschen größer class
Text xl
Ja gar nicht mal so kacke jetzt müssen wir nur noch gucken oder das weiß ich immer nicht
Checker high IQ css kenner wie kriege ich das auto
allein
auf die höhe von meiner schrift jetzt
Das ist ein flex box das ist glaube ich irgendwas es ist das so
flex allein center
center so was hier vielleicht vielleicht sowas wie
einfach wieder item center
okay
Und was macht es unter der hause unter der haube allein item center okay
Hier
Was nicht flex direction ne oder acht keine ahnung ich blicke nicht durch was css angeht
Okay und jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich die die idee passt mal auf wenn wenn gerade daten gefädscht werden
Eikens wenn gerade daten gefälscht werden dann machen wir folgendes
Zeigen wir ein Refresh-Icon an, ja das hier ist gut, wie heißt das Ding, wie heißt das
Icon?
Rotate clockwise to, alles klar, Rotate clockwise to, na mal da, Rotate clockwise to, haben
wir das da?
Und passt mal auf, CSS Magic, Tailwind Magic Deluxe, wir sagen jetzt Text Warning, aus
irgendwelchen Gründen, dass man es einfach besser sieht und jetzt sagen wir Spin, Animation
Spin, Animate Spin, Bam, Koggers, jetzt wird Refreshed, ist also nicht das krasseste Refresh-Icon
ever, guck mal, wie schön es rotiert, ich kann, ich glaube man kann, konnte man das
nicht auch Reverse Rotaten lassen in Tailwind, dass man die Animation umdreht, Tailwind,
Spin, Counter, Clockwise, da musste man doch irgendwas eintragen, ne das klingt doch viel
einfacher, hier, Rotate, Transform, Rotate 180 kann man machen, guck mal, äh, ah, ne,
hm, ich würde sagen das ist ein bisschen kaputt, ja, dann lassen wir es mal lieber
so, das sieht gar nicht mal so ultra kacke aus, Animation versus Transition, ach muss
ich Animation dann weg machen, ne, das Icon ist unpassend, warum, wenn es gerade Refreshed,
wenn gerade neue Daten geladen werden, ist das doch gar nicht so übel, achso, du meinst
ohne Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, aber Punkt, Punkt, Punkt ist doch eigentlich ganz gut, wenn gerade
Refreshed wird, ich mein, es sollte vielleicht nicht unbedingt überall dran stehen, aber
wenn gerade Refreshed wird, ist das doch, ist nice, auch ein Refresh-Icon, das ist eigentlich
nice, guck mal, alternativ, wir hätten auch sowas hier, einfach rein Koggers einbauen,
wir hätten auch das hier, wir hätten ein Refresh und ein Refresh-Dot, ok, Refresh,
das muss ich mal ausprobieren, Refresh, ok, das geht auch, das ist aber falsch rum jetzt,
Leute, es Rotated falsch rum und ich weiß nicht, wie ich es richtig rum Rotaten lasse,
wie war das, Style, Reverse Animation oder was hat da jemand gerade geschrieben, Reverse,
Komplette Seite spiegeln, beste, beste Idee, dass man sich immer mit so kleinen Scheiß
aufhalten muss ey, hier, Animation, Direction, Reverse, ey, funktioniert, nice, ok, aber
das ist kacke, oder, ich mein, wie sieht denn so ein ordentlicher, wie sieht denn so ein
ordentlicher Spinner aus, so, die, die drehen sich alle Clockwise und meiner dreht sich
Counter-Clockwise, das ist doch, das ist doch dumm, Moment, hier dreht er sich auch Counter-Clockwise,
ne, jetzt dreht er sich nicht Counter-Clockwise, jetzt dreht er sich Clockwise, macht doch
einfach wie eben und dann spiegeln, ja, sagt mir mal, wie ich spiegel, gibt es sowas wie
Mirror, ey, keine Ahnung, wie man das spiegelt, ich hab doch, das Icon spiegeln, ja, und wie,
CSS, Mirror, Icon, einfach das Icon reversen, ja, easy, just do it, so schonmal nicht, bestimmt
irgendwelche super krassen CSS-Styles wieder, wie reverse, how to flip an image, ok, CSS,
transform, scale minus 1, perfekt, perfection, alter, CSS macht mich jedes Mal verrückt,
dieser Scheiß, man, besser, besser Reload überhaupt, gell, ah, guck mal, der, der addet
schon einen Transform hier dazu, der addet einen Transform, Rotate, lass es bitte so,
alter, sieht das hängengeblieben aus, size, wir machen das mal ein bisschen kleiner, das
ist eigentlich viel zu groß, so, es, sagt mal, Leute, eiert das nicht auch ein bisschen,
schaut mal, ne, das sieht nur so aus, glaube ich, CSS-Animation, es dreht auch viel zu
sehr, ja, keine Ahnung, wie man das, wie man das besser animiert, das ist kein Spinner,
das ist einfach ein Icon, was ich mit, mit dieser Tailwind-Spin-Animation animate, was
haben die denn sonst noch zu bieten, animate bounce, ja, perfekt, äh, Tailwind-Transform,
vielleicht kann man den Kram auch irgendwie anders machen, wow, äh, kann das sein, dass,
oh, meine Auge, meine Auge, alter, oh, ich brauch das irgendwie, oh, oh, oh, close, close
call, ja, animate, guck mal, der hat so einen richtig Pogger-Spinner, der Dude, das will
ich auch haben, wie macht der das, das ist Massive-Hier-Queue-Spinner, ah, der verrät
nicht, wie er das macht, ach so, der hat dann einfach ein SVG, das Ural-Doku, ne, ach, V3,
äh, Animate, ey, gut, hat sich jetzt ja nicht viel geändert, guck mal, der hat wieder so
einen Pog-Spinner, wo haben die denn diesen, diesen Pogger, okay, warte mal, Hero-Icons
ist doch das von Tailwind, da haben die das doch bestimmt her, äh, Spinner, Refresh,
ne, wo haben die das her, das muss ich mir jetzt klauen, SVG, ja, weiß nicht, wo haben
die das her, ich will das, ich klau das jetzt nicht so einfach, wo, wo, wo haben die, wo
haben die das her, wir suchen einfach danach, guck mal, das ist das, das ist das SVG, aha,
copied from, nice, guck mal, wir copy-pasten das einfach von dem Typ hier, das ist der
official Tailwind-Spinner, ja, dann schauen wir mal, wie der aussieht, also wirklich official
ist er nicht, boah, alter, was ein nicer Spinner, Moment, Skeleton hat sowas schon, ja, hätte
ich das mal gewusst, ähm, was, Progress, Progress-Radiant, aha, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
aha, aha, ja, easy, Progress-Radiant, ach, easy, guck mal, da kannst du sogar unterschiedliche
Farben machen, Massive Cogger-Spinner, einfach so, okay, ja, dann machen wir jetzt den Krempel
doch mal weg, okay, das müssen wir importen, ähm, Skeleton, hier, Progress-Radiant, ja,
ah, warum auch Spinner, wenn man das Progress-Radiant nennen kann, ja, richtig feinfertig, ja, da
wäre ich im Leben nicht drauf gekommen, dass es dort Spinner gibt, naja, alles gut, Funzd,
okay, bisschen groß ist das Ganze vielleicht, so minimal, minimal groß, gibt's da Property-Size
oder sowas? Ah, hier, Width, breta, größer ist perfekt, würde ich sagen, oh, ja, besser
Bisschen, bisschen könnte man, vielleicht auch ein bisschen größer, hä?
So, Class...
Hä?
Was ist denn hier los? Size?
Width? Achso.
Was muss man da angeben?
Ach, da gibt man die Tailwinds an.
B12
Ah, ja, ja, okay.
Aber das sieht kleiner natürlich schon ziemlich kacke aus, gell?
Das erkennt man, das erkennt man kaum.
Ich würd sagen, 5 ist prinzipiell ne gute Größe, aber da muss der Strich dicker sein.
Ach hier, Stroke.
Stroke
Gleich 10
Ah, da ist es ganz dünn. 90
Ah, ey, das sieht gar nicht so schlecht aus jetzt.
Leute, ich muss mal sagen,
das sieht gar nicht so mies aus.
Ich find, also...
Ich find das eigentlich ganz gut jetzt sogar.
Ja.
Das gefällt mir.
Nice, das sieht richtig gut aus.
Das sieht aus wie so ein...
Wie ich mir das von der Webseite vorstellen würde,
halt mit so einem Spinner.
Bald Webdesigner, ja?
Ja, ich häng das mit
Linux und so an den Nagel.
Ich mach gleich Webdesigner.
Ne, machen wir nicht.
Weil die explizit sagen,
dass man das damit machen kann. Guck.
Das sieht gut aus. Gefällt mir.
Ist das richtig
aligned?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das ganz in der Mitte ist,
Leute. Ich würde sagen,
das ist nicht ganz in der Mitte.
Das ist ein bisschen zu hoch.
Oder was? Was denkt ihr?
Ich würde sagen, das ist ein bisschen zu hoch.
Sag ich so nie, wie kriegen wir das
runter?
Ach hier muss ich...
Schaust dir mal
in den Devtools an.
Ach deswegen,
weil das eigentlich viereckig ist,
sind die Bounds nicht...
Ne.
Wie kriege ich das jetzt runter?
Ich meine, man könnte
einfach sowas sagen wie...
Wir könnten sagen, Position
absolut und es dann
da hinschieben.
Für sowas bin ich eindeutig zu pp-iger.
Ich habe wirklich
nicht die leisesten Schimmer eine Ahnung,
wie ich diesen Spinner ordentlich
positionieren würde.
Was müsste funktionieren?
Okay, hat das jetzt was gemacht?
Ne. Hat das überhaupt einen Unterschied?
Ach, ich bin ja auch doof. Ich brauche hier extra
Glasses.
Nicht in der Width, Alter.
Aber das...
Wahrscheinlich klappt es trotzdem, weil er das in die Glass reinpackt.
Interessiert dich die
Webentwicklung nicht so sehr? Doch.
Aber es ist nicht unbedingt was, was ich hauptberuflich machen will.
Alter...
CSS...
Okay und...
Was bin ich jetzt da sehend?
Für mich sieht es jetzt so richtig
aligned aus. Ach,
guck mal! Meine Schrift...
Die Schrift ist nicht richtig in der Mitte.
Kann das sein? Guck mal, bei
der Klammer ist viel mehr Platz oben
als unten. Boah,
wie mich sowas abfuckt, Alter.
Der Fiat ist richtig.
Die Klammer? Warum ist die
Klammer so komisch? Liegt das an
der Schriftart, oder?
Das liegt einfach an der Schriftart, oder?
Die Schriftart ist pp-iger.
Versuch mal ein Lionhide. Ach was.
Ich lass das jetzt einfach so.
Wo Lionhide? Hier?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das
in Tailwind macht.
Leading. Hier, da wäre ich jetzt aber nicht
drauf gekommen.
Leading? What the fuck?
None.
Es geht nur eins.
Es geht gar nicht null. Ah nee,
du willst eins machen.
Hat sich da jetzt was geändert?
Nicht wirklich, oder?
Leute, warum machen wir mit so einem Scheiß wieder schon
so ewig rum? Nee, hier ändert
sich da einfach gar nichts.
Versuch mal Items.
Baseline.
Okay, das ist noch mehr kaputt.
Noch mehr broken.
Ja, komm. Scheiß drauf.
Ich schieb's einfach
auf die Schriftart. Okay, Leute,
wisst ihr was?
Items end?
Nee, das sollte doch jetzt hier nichts bringen, oder?
Das hat keinen Unterschied.
Das interessiert den überhaupt nicht, den Spinner.
Okay, wisst ihr, was wir jetzt machen?
Pass mal auf.
Ach, weil der Auto hatte.
Max, wir probieren
das mal aus.
Aha.
Nee, jetzt ist es zu weit unten.
TSS, Alter.
Jetzt ist es zu weit unten.
Item Center.
Und jetzt ist es zu weit oben.
Okay.
Ist mir egal. Pass mal auf.
Relative.
Bester Fix.
Absolute.
Top.
Äh.
Warum? Warum bewegt sich
das nicht? Sollte das
jetzt nicht eigentlich dort sein?
Was ist da? Was ist da?
Warum geht das nicht?
Muss ich da vielleicht eine Klasse drumherum machen?
Ah.
Ich lag das auch daran, dass das nicht
funktioniert hat.
Ja.
Position.
Top. Nee, das ist auch
kacke. Ach, das ist alles.
Wisst ihr was? Scheiß drauf. Ich lasse es jetzt einfach so.
Bäm. Fällt doch eh
keinem auf. Warum soll man mit so einem kack Spinner
jetzt so ewig rummachen? So, das bleibt jetzt einfach
so. Easy. Weiter geht's.
Wäre ja immer noch für Rotate
Clockwise Icon
und Animate
Spin Klasse. Nä.
Ich baue jetzt nicht noch
weiter mit dem Spinner rum.
So.
Das sollte er eigentlich auch nur anzeigen, wenn er gerade lädt.
Also.
Was brauchen wir denn sonst noch? Hier
in der Section
würde ich
sagen, brauchen wir sowas
wie
Account
Active oder sowas.
Fällt mir gerade nichts
Spannendes zu ein.
Ähm.
Wie kriege ich denn das jetzt nach
links? Und ne Moment.
Ich will ja da zwei Sachen rein
machen.
Und das ganze dann nochmal.
Kriege ich denn das jetzt nach links?
Das auch einfach Flex machen?
Äh. Und jetzt? So was wie Flex Call?
Geht das? Äh.
Shit. Wäre jetzt zu einfach gewesen.
Du hast
oben Text Center.
Ach tatsächlich.
Warum habe ich denn sowas?
Was macht denn das da?
Geh mal bloß weg damit.
So. Ach ja.
Wir können jetzt bei der Stelle noch einstellen, dass wir sagen
ähm.
Das soll so breit sein wie der Bildschirm.
Ne, das funktioniert so nicht.
Warum nicht?
So vielleicht?
Ne.
Äh.
Ich hätte es fast vermutet.
Warum geht das nicht?
Sollte das jetzt nicht einfach breiter
breiter werden?
BG Red. Ist das denn jetzt wenigstens
breiter? Ah.
Okay. Das ist eigentlich schon breiter.
So will ich das eigentlich
haben. Ja.
Aber wie kriegt man das ganze Ding denn jetzt breiter?
Nächste.
Ah.
Five Head Chat.
Beste. Ja.
So ist das gut.
Ist das nice. Guck mal.
Jetzt scale das auch.
So breit werde ich das wahrscheinlich nie
brauchen. Aber.
Hyper responsive.
So jetzt müssen wir an der Stelle glaube ich
noch einstellen,
dass wir Space Between haben
wollen. Ne.
Ne nicht Content Between.
Between. Wie heißt das?
Justify.
Ja.
Nice.
Das sieht jetzt schon ganz okay aus.
Finde ich.
So was müssen denn da für
Infos rein im Endeffekt?
Das ist wenn man schon einen Account geedit
hat. So da schreiben wir sowas rein wie
Account active.
So keine Ahnung. Cars. Anzahl.
Das ist nicht zwei.
Ähm.
Das ist nicht.
Updated. Irgendwie so keine Ahnung.
Äh four minutes
ago.
Und irgendwie sowas wie
Intervall. Ich rate
jetzt einfach mal so was man da so reinschreiben könne.
Okay.
Und hier unten
Total Cars Edit.
Ne also was ich vorhab ist folgendes.
Wir brauchen hier noch ein
Add Button. Das ist ein Account
der geedit wurde.
Das ist quasi die Account Übersicht.
Und das reicht an Infos ja
eigentlich schon.
Ich mein
die eigentlichen Sachen sehen die Leute ja dann
in ihrem Smart Home oder in ihrem MQTT
oder im Log oder so.
Aber es geht mir eigentlich
nicht so sehr drum dass das ein krasses Dashboard ist
wo man alle Informationen zum Auto sehen kann.
Das wäre ja Overkill.
Einfach nur zum Accounts adden und sehen ob die Accounts
funktionieren.
Brauchst du ein Webfrontend für mein Home Assistant
Addon?
Okay.
Mein Home Assistant Addon und
es haben immer mehr Leute geschrieben
sie würden sich auch wünschen dass man das Standalone
verwenden kann. Und die
in Home Assistant eingebaute
Config ist auch ein bisschen suboptimal.
Weil du nicht beliebig viele Accounts
hier drin anlegen kannst.
Ja.
Aber es ist doch gar nicht so übel.
Ich würde sagen wir brauchen noch ein Button.
Und zwar hier unten brauchen wir ein Button.
Button.
Und zwar
einen Button mit einem Trash Icon.
Beste.
Oder K-Off Icon.
Probieren wir mal aus.
Button.
K-Off.
Also anstelle von Delete.
Aber das versteht dann wieder keiner.
Also Button.
Class.
Ich glaube es gibt sowas wie
Image.
Btn Icon.
Will ich überhaupt.
Ich muss dem einfach nur Btn.
Ich muss dem Ding mal
eine Farbe
geben.
Filt.
Error.
Äh.
Das sieht ja kacke aus.
Button.
Oder doch Btn Icon.
Hä?
Aber das ist rund.
Das ist doof.
Ja.
Das ist gar nicht mal so übel.
Nur dass das schon ein Trash Icon sein sollte.
Anstatt
ein Auto.
Sammel Jason mit einer Liste nicht einfacher.
Doch aber ein Webinterface ist nicer.
Skeleton hat doch Buttons.
Ja das sind ja die Skeleton Buttons hier.
Wir machen mal Trash.
Trash.
Keine Ahnung das hier.
Mal wie das aussieht.
Ja.
Ey das geht doch eigentlich voll klar.
Das geht doch eigentlich voll klar.
Das Trash Icon hier.
Und wie sieht das ohne?
Ohne Filt aus?
Ja das ist besser.
Button unten rechts.
Okay.
Also das heißt.
Pass mal auf.
Wie ich das jetzt 5 Header mäßig löse.
Flex.
Und.
Äh.
Einfach wieder justify between.
Easy.
Schon ist der Button rechts.
Aber das dumme ist jetzt.
Hm.
Ey da war ja einfach ein leeres Diff davor.
Hahahaha.
So kann man es auch machen oder?
Ah ne was?
Was war das?
MS Auto?
Ey das funktioniert auch.
Alter der Chat ist wieder massive next level brain.
Und was ist wenn man ein Auto
aus der Liste löschen will?
Gar nicht. Man kann keine Autos aus der Liste löschen.
Das macht doch keinen Sinn.
Das ist einfach nur eine Anzeige ist.
Von deinem Fiat oder Alfa Romeo oder so Account.
Verschwindet ja nicht einfach dein Auto.
Du kannst dir das nicht löschen.
Das ist read only an der Stelle.
Du kannst nur Sachen auslesen.
Das einzige wo du halt Sachen schicken kannst ist
Sachen wie beispielsweise Licht an
ans Auto.
Aber du kannst nicht in deinem Account
dein Auto entfernen oder sowas.
M steht für margin.
S steht für ähm.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Margin. Start.
Auto. Alter Chat.
Ihr seid so schlau.
Woher weiß man sowas?
Danke für die Subs. Ich hab mir die Hälfte
übersehen. Miami Pie.
Random Win. Komax.
Noah Lost Pancakes.
Alex Dronik.
Der Rüpel.
Seven Lars.
Das hab ich mir gemerkt dass der Lars heißt.
Sagen Silva auch wieder
am Start. Alle nicht mitbekommen.
Der addet immer 2 Autos
wenn 2 im Fiat Account sind.
Gell. Nö.
Achso. Ja.
Warum sag ich nö.
Oder 3 wenn 3 im Fiat Account
sind. Leute so
schlecht sieht das hier an der Stelle
finde ich gar nicht mehr aus.
Das heißt wir brauchen jetzt noch nen Add Button.
Den machen wir einfach ganz fett
hier oben drüber.
Haben wir hier irgendwie sowas wie nen
Tabler Icon.
Add. Add. Alarm.
Ne.
Plus. Ich muss noch plus
suchen. Plus.
Alarm plus. Bell
plus. Ok. Pass mal auf. Gibt es
K plus? Das wär natürlich
mega. Ne das gibt's natürlich nicht.
Ich mein. Braucht auch niemand normalerweise
in seiner App. Ok.
Plus. Plus.
Cloud plus?
Oder einfach nur plus?
Ja einfach nur K ist
nicht so geil. Circle
plus? File plus?
Herzchen plus?
Ja wahrscheinlich
einfach nur. Square
rounded plus
filled. Das find ich gut.
Was war das? Navigation
plus? Ne.
Das ist gut. Also wie heißt
dieses Ding? Square
rounded
plus
filled.
Was? Das Icon Namen man.
So. Wo kommt
der Button jetzt hin?
Hier? So direkt?
Ja ey. Direkt da oben drüber.
Was war das? Icon
square filled?
Ne. Oh Gott. Was?
Ja. Das sieht gar
nicht mal so kacke aus.
Button
So. Jetzt ist es schon mal nen Button was man klicken
kann. Also
Glass
BTN
BTNLG
Filled
Variant? Ne wie geht das?
Alter muss ich mal. Das kann ich mir immer nicht merken.
Wie funzt das hier? Buttons
Buttons
Ja.
Da kann man unten auswählen wie es aussehen soll.
Filled Surface
Ghost Variant
Ah da sind die durchsichtig.
Ghost Primary
Soft
Alter wie viele Varianten? Alter
wie viele? Was zum?
Wie viele Varianten für Buttons haben die denn?
Guckt euch das mal an.
BG Gradient to BR
Variant Gradient Error Warning
Ja.
Nice.
Das ist exakt das was ich brauch.
Ich finde das würde gar nicht
so dumm aussehen.
Aber das probiere ich jetzt mal aus.
BG Gradient
Ne was?
To
BR
Was zum mache ich da überhaupt?
Abverläufe
Ach du scheiße.
Variant Gradient
Error
Ne Error
Error Warning
Boah Next Level Button
Massive Button
Geilster Button überhaupt.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Da klickt jeder sofort drauf auf diesen Poggers Button.
Size
Gleich Bettge ja.
Welch Massive Button.
Pog Button
ALG war schon ok.
Zack.
Was ein krasser Button.
Ja.
Ich würde mir auch gleich noch ein neues Auto kaufen.
Nur für den Button.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Das sieht gar nicht mal so übel aus.
Mit dem Farbverlauf.
Was im Designkurs durchgefallen.
Warum?
Weil zu viele unterschiedliche Farben.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Also Alternative.
Gradients sind Out.
Ringed Error
Ghost Soft
Ghost Success
Ghost Primary
Ok.
Variant Ghost
Das ist auch gut.
Was ist die 60-30-10 Regel?
Die 60-30-10 Regel.
Heute lernen wir noch.
Designer Fallverzeug
Die Einrichtungsregel.
Ne nicht wirklich oder?
Ein Dekorations Trick.
Euch erleichtern Ausgrund Farbschimmer.
60 steht für 60%.
60% Hauptfarbe.
Was?
Ok hier kriegen wir es erklärt.
Nein.
60%
Ok.
60% Dominant Color.
30% Secondary Color.
Und 10%
Oh man.
Die Seite ist ja abartig.
Ok.
Dann machen wir das so.
Vollgas.
Achja und das Allerwichtigste.
Habe ich ja noch fast vergessen.
Light Switch muss natürlich da rein.
Das ist das letzte was wir heute machen.
Aber das muss sein.
Light Switch.
Was ist das?
Irgendwas was damit nichts zu tun hat.
Light Switch.
Und jetzt ganz wichtig.
Der muss hier oben auch noch rein.
Direkt auf die rechte Seite nehmen wir den Fiat Champ.
Zack.
Und jetzt sagen wir hier auch noch.
Und Diff.
Kann man das so machen?
Kann man das hier flexen?
Weird Flex.
Oh.
Ok.
Dann.
Sehr Weird Flex.
Wie kriegen wir das hin?
Ach Trail gibt es hier.
Guck mal.
Vielleicht können wir das einfach hier reinpacken.
Easy.
Kann ich da?
Sehr schön.
Guckt mal.
Wir können jetzt
Dark und Light Theme umschalten.
Huge.
Was für ein Pog aus Design.
Naja.
Ich denke für das wofür es da ist
wird das ausreichend sein.
Als nächstes müssen wir
im Backend ein bisschen was einbauen.
Dass ich auch mal ein paar Daten zurückbekomme.
Und da sinnvoll was anzeigen lassen kann.
Ein paar Fake.
Ein paar Fake Daten.
Das sieht
ohne Mist Leute, wenn man sich das jetzt mal so anguckt.
Das sieht gar nicht so kacke aus.
Oder?
Ich meine das ist jetzt nicht die hohe Designerkunst.
Aber es geht irgendwo.
Ich meine das hier sollte nur erscheinen
wenn er auch wirklich refresht.
Und irgendwie so ganz glücklich bin ich
so wie das aussieht noch nicht.
Aber so vom großen und ganzen
auch dass man hier den Add Button hat
wo jeder weiß dass er den gefälligst drücken soll
um was hinzuzufügen.
Es ist gar nicht mal so kacke.
Ich meine vielleicht sollten wir noch
vielleicht sollten wir den Button immer
vielleicht sollten wir den Button auch noch hier oben rein machen
oder so. Aber im großen und ganzen.
Ja.
Leute wir widmen uns
demnächst
weiter dem WebUI
für den Frontend
Fiat Champ.
Ich muss jetzt ins Bett.
Sleepge.
Bettge.
Boomer müde. Boomer schlafen.
Muss ich jetzt machen.
Schon spät. Shadow LG noch
auf die Kart. Okay das mach ich mal schnell.
Das interessiert mich nämlich noch wie das aussieht.
Refreshen.
Auf die Kart.
Mal kurz gucken.
Shadow LG.
Hey.
Sehr gut.
Hier guck mal. Die Kart sticht jetzt
richtig raus. Guck mal.
Viel besser mit Shadow als ohne Shadow.
Richtig nice.
Nice.
Jetzt sieht es ja
Web 8.0
aus.
Okay next.
Das gefällt mir jetzt. An der Stelle können wir weitermachen.
Danke für die Subs Leute.
Wenn euch der Stream gefallen hat und ihr mehr sowas sehen wollt
dann könnt ihr mir ja auch folgen.
Kleiner Sellout am Rande.
Und wir sehen uns im nächsten
Stream. Bis dann.
Machts gut.
CU jetzt.
Ahja Leute ich hab übrigens eine Fitness Uhr gekauft.
Da kann ich demnächst
meinen Schlafmonitoren mit.
Bis dann. CU.